Tsar wasn't playing basketball what job
would he have I think he would say a
broadcaster probably broadcast what job
would you have if you weren't playing
basketball probably do broadcast too he
would probably be a broadcaster well
what does Sarah say is his favorite meal
salmon in and out but I'ma say salmon
what would a man say is his favorite
meal he's gonna say chicken it's your
favorite meal it's chicken what would a
sour say your
poor he's like three to five pounds
bigger than me at all times a man's most
jealous of me furry he says the way I
moved
his dunks he has a cooler dunk bags than
me it's got to be um our looks he got
the short end of the stick what would a
star say it was the worst thing he ever
did as a kid as I was a pretty chill kid
I don't know so I didn't do a lot a
nicer kid than a man what was the worst
thing you
know I say fight I didn't fight for real
I just wrestled and that was an
aggressive child he used to try to hurt
me
the more recent a couple months ago last
one on one game he beat man